ok folgendes gedankenexperiment stell
dir vor eine böse hexe verflucht die
menschheit mit ihrem fluch verschwinden
plötzlich alle menschengemachten objekte
auf der welt computer autos straßen
uhren dank dach über dem kopf alles ist
plötzlich weg und du stehst nackt da mit
7,7 milliarden anderen nackten menschen
wir leben also wieder wie vor 200.000
jahren die einzige möglichkeit die wir
diesen flug umkehren können
die menschheit muss ein voll
funktionsfähiges iphone bauen
die frage ist nun wie lange würden wir
dafür brauchen uns noch ein paar regeln
klarzustellen die hexe müsste dieses
iphone theoretisch in einen apple store
bringen und ist die mitarbeitern zeigen
können ohne dass diesen etwas auffällt
ergo es muss sich anfühlen wie ein ganz
normales iphone face id funktioniert
apps lassen sich installieren und so
weiter wie lange braucht die menschheit
also um so ein iphone herzustellen
darum geht es heute und falls ihnen
kanal noch nicht abonniert habt dann
macht das doch gerne viel spaß
du und ich habe keine ahnung wie man ein
iphone produziert die allermeisten
menschen auf diesem planeten haben das
nicht aber es gibt glücklicherweise eine
kleine gruppe menschen die es weiß
nämlich die über 12.000 apple
mitarbeiter auf dem apple campus in
cupertino kalifornien darunter eine
menge an talentierten entwicklern
designern und ingenieuren die mit allen
funktionen des iphones vertraut sind
trotz fehlender büros und wahrscheinlich
auch kleidung sollte diesen entwicklern
schnell klar geworden sein dass die
zukunft der erde in ihren händen liegt
der erste sinnvolle schritt wäre
wahrscheinlich alles aufzuschreiben was
für die produktion des iphones wichtig
ist alle abmessungen details und
produktionsschritte an die sie sich noch
erinnern können
normalerweise dauert es ein jahr bis ein
neues iphone heraus kommt also ein jahr
bis die hexe ihr iphone in der hand hält
naja wenn man erst mal anfängt darüber
nachzudenken dann fallen einem immer
mehr kleine probleme auf zum beispiel
gibt es nichts zum aufschreiben jeder
kugelschreiber und jedes stück papier
sind verschwunden und natürlich gibt es
auch keine computer die wären aber
natürlich für die soft aber auch für die
hardwareentwicklung ziemlich praktisch
gewesen mikrochips und bildschirme für
computer und auch das iphone selber
wurden größtenteils in asien hergestellt
also finden sich auch dort fähige
menschen zwar sind die produktionsketten
sehr fragmentiert die richtigen leute
lassen sich aber bestimmt finden
wir müssen also eine verbindung zwischen
dem apple ingenieuren in den usa und den
foxconn mitarbeitern in china herstellen
leider gibt es aber natürlich auch keine
telefonleitungen um einfach mal
anzurufen es gibt nicht mal eine
infrastruktur zum verschicken von
briefen und mit der flaschenpost würden
unsere bemühungen wahrscheinlich ins
offene meer gespült werden
bleibt also eigentlich nur eine
expedition um von amerika nach china zu
kommen müssten die apple ingenieure über
alaska und russland wandern
an der behringstraße müssten sie
allerdings 82 kilometer weit segeln
dafür wiederum müssten die schiffe bauen
schwierig aber gut machbar
wir haben also hoffentlich eine
verbindung hergestellt dann kann die
produktion ja beginnen
leider recht pures fachwissen aber auch
nicht aus die produktion eines iphones
benötigt aluminium silizium kobalt chrom
alles ressourcen die ohne werkzeuge und
industrie ketten sehr schwierig zu
bekommen sind
und selbst wenn das geschafft wäre
braucht es maschinen und werkzeuge um
die materialien zu bearbeiten also
brauchen wir auch die spezialisten und
ressourcen für diese maschinen nur china
und die usa rechnen also nicht aus
allein für die herstellung der kamera
und des bildschirms vom iphone müsste
man nach japan reisen der kamera sensor
in japan wurde allerdings wieder mit
hilfe eines objektivs aus deutschland
hergestellt und dieses objektiv ist so
schwer dass man es nicht ohne
industrielle roboter herstellen kann
industrielle roboter brauchen aber
wiederum kabel elektromotoren sensoren
ihr seht diese kette ist beinahe endlos
selbst wenn ein netzwerk aus allen
angestellten in der apple
produktionskette und darüber hinaus
aufgebaut würde dann wären wir zwar
näher an täuschend echte hardware
software stellt aber noch mal ein ganz
eigenes problem dar
wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass wir
einen apple mitarbeiter täuschen wollen
also müssen wir auch unendlich viele
kleinigkeiten achten die die software
experience eines modernen smartphones
ausmachen
ios das iphone betriebssystem ist
mittlerweile in seiner 13 generation
die aktuelle software experience baut
auf 12 vorherigen versionen auf
animationen icons und selbst so
kleinigkeiten wie die scroll
geschwindigkeit unterlaufen einem
evolutionären prozess wir haben es mit
2,2 gigawatt an co zu tun die sich
unmöglichsten jemand merken kann welche
entwickler kann sich schon an den
exakten farbcode für jeden button seiner
app erinnern
in der praxis kommen dann also eine
reihe von weiteren bauteilen
arbeitsschritten rohstoffen werkzeugen
und auch fachpersonal von überall auf
der welt hinzu es würde jahre dauern bis
es erstmal eine kommunikation zwischen
potenziellen produktionsstätten und
spezialisten gibt es würde weitere
jahrzehnte oder noch länger dauern bis
wir infrastruktur maschinen und supply
chains aufgebaut haben
erst dann könnte man mit der entwicklung
von der software überhaupt beginnen
sagen wir also mal 250 jahre bis wir das
iphone hergestellt haben
so lange haben wir gebraucht um vom
beginn der industrialisierung bis heute
zukommen
aber wenn wir alle zusammenhalten dann
sollte das auch machbar sein oder
nun ja realistisch gesehen stehen wir
sobald der fluch der hexe wird vor einer
humanitären katastrophe
wahrscheinlich wird der erste impuls auf
dem ehemaligen apple campus nicht seine
baupläne und kot festzuhalten sondern
wasser zu finden vor allem in
ballungsräumen werden millionen nackter
menschen zur nächsten wasserquellen was
eine hygienische katastrophe hervorrufen
würde
und selbst wenn sie es schaffen sollten
wasser zu finden wo finden sie essen die
meisten von uns haben nie gelernt zu
jagen getreide anzubauen oder hütten zu
errichten wo findet man überhaupt wilde
tiere und welche pilze und beeren darf
ich essen
wir würden einen massensterben erleben
wenn du nicht bereits heute selbst
versorgen lebst dann wirst du mit großer
wahrscheinlichkeit in wenigen monaten
verhungern oder an einer schlimmen
krankheit sterben
selbst wenn durch ein wunder die
ernährung von 7,7 milliarden menschen
ohne technische hilfsmittel organisiert
werden kann
dann haben wir immer noch nicht die
gesellschaftlichen konsequenzen des
flugs bedacht alle existierenden
politischen systeme werden sofort
zusammenbrechen
es herrscht anarchie selbst wenn zu
anfang alle menschen an einem strang
ziehen würden dann würde es genug
gruppen geben sie in diesem fluch eine
art neuanfang
diese gruppen werden aktiv gegen die
konstruktion des iphones arbeiten wollen
wir also zurück ins jahr 2020 dann ist
konflikt unvermeidbar wahrscheinlich
bilden sich auch gangs und sich so
gegenseitig schutz zu bieten vielleicht
verfallen wir sogar in einen neuen
feudalismus wenn du dich eine mafia boss
verpflichtet ist dann bietet er die im
gegenzug schutz
dafür musste allerdings für ihn arbeiten
nach und nach werden alle menschen
sterben die wussten wir ein iphone
gebaut und programmiert wurde mit
weiteren jahren werden alle menschen
sterben die überhaupt wissen was ein
iphone war
so wird das iphone über die jahre
wahrscheinlich zu einem mystischen
objekt eine legende die man seinen
kindern vor dem lagerfeuer erzählt
unter diesen bedingungen rückt ein
iphone das funktionsfähig ist und alles
machen kann was ein heutiges iphone kann
in unerreichbare ferne
ich finde das gedankenexperiment mega
spannend und je länger ich darüber
nachdenke desto mehr wird mir der umfang
dieses experiments bewusst selbst wenn
wir es schaffen würden nach vielen
hundert jahren das perfekte iphone zu
bauen
fast an inzwischen leben ganz andere
menschen auf der erde
menschen die noch nie in der modernen
welt des einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts
gelebt haben und mit computern autos und
supermärkten gar nichts anfangen können
was mir das experiment klar macht ist
dass wir auf den schultern von riesen
stehen
alles was wir als menschheit erdacht und
erfunden haben baut aufeinander auf eine
kutsche der jetzt kein auto ohne
rechenschieber der es keine computer der
menschliche fortschritt ist eine leiter
auf der wir stehen wenn wir von dieser
leiter herunter geschubst werden dann
können wir nicht einfach wieder oben
einsteigen nur weil wir wissen wie es
hier oben aussieht wir müssen die leiter
wieder ganz von unten nach oben
erklimmen
okay das waren meine gedanken zu diesem
gedanken experiment das wurde übrigens
ursprünglich von cameron vom blog great
but why postuliert der dazu auf seinem
blog ein paar echt spannende gedanken
aufgeschrieben gelingt dazu packt
erstmal unten in die video beschreibung
und generell way drei sehr sehr cool
website schaut euch denkt gerne mal um
jetzt bin ich aber mega gespannt was ihr
dazu zu sagen habt wann werden wir das
iphone herstellen wenn überhaupt ich hab
mal eine umfrage gemacht bitte gerne
daran teilnehmen aber natürlich wird
mich auch interessieren was ich noch
vergessen habe was in dieser fiktiven
welt noch alles bedacht werden muss was
sind eure ansätze schreibt es mir gerne
unten in die kommentare
ich freue mich schon sehr mit euch
zusammen zu diskutieren
dahin bleibt neugierig orchester 3
[Musik]